hi I'm Ben Shaw stack and barn your
intelligence games and I made high
strangeness it's a retro
action-adventure game where you get the
ability to switch between 8 and 16-bit
worlds the 8-bit world is kind of
inspired by legend zelda on the nes and
it has that that old-school color
palette and you move in four directions
and you have kind of like pokey jab as
your attack and you can switch into the
16-bit world the 16-bit world is more
inspired by games like Secret of Mana
other action RPGs on the Super NES and
in in that world you have more ability
to run around and do combo attacks and
part of the game is watercolor
illustration fit kind of are inspired by
the vivid illustration in instruction
manuals of old school pixel games so for
example original Legend of Zelda came
with a you know beautiful hand-drawn map
and drawn illustration to all the
characters even though they just made up
a few pixels in the game and one thing
that's special about our game is that it
was the first ever kick-started game
back in two thousand nine and it's been
a passion project for us and really we
love working on it and all the the
influences are things that we we love
and we want to make something that
smells all together
of the since a year and a half ago well
year and a half ago was the first time
we showed it to anybody outside our
development team and since then we've
been crunching on really hard past year
and a half and we're almost done with it
we've got like all the puzzles and all
the levels done we're doing the final
polishing since then we we got greenlit
on steam for coming out on pc mac and
linux and also on consoles and we've
been picked up by midnight city and
working with them has been awesome
because they helped give us that push to
get all of the the pixel art done and
also to help get the game out there for
people to see so the story is mysterious
do you wake up in your house to find
these strange phantom men walking about
harassing you and your cat to your cat
runs after them and you give chase so
you defeat all these guys and kick them
out of your house and they leave behind
this crystal skull it's red skull and
that skull it turns out your cat is
telling you about it because he talks
and he knows more about what's going on
than you do but he tells you it gives
you a vision ability and that vision
ability is the 8 and 16-bit switch that
we're talking about and so this portal
dimension you can see the the effect
where you switch between the worlds and
it's you can see the inspiration from
cartridge games with the corruption
glitches that pop up so the the
different worlds are are parallel so
it's
a multi-dimensional reality and right
now you can see Boyd has the ability to
switch between them it will and it
completely changes how the game plays
and all the enemies you can see there
they're affected just as well as as much
as you are so in the 16-bit world you
can see you've run faster you can do
combos the reasons you switch between
the worlds are for for combat reasons
and also you can see there's there's
puzzles that they're dependent on the
differences in the world so for example
for this one if he was in 8-bit he
wouldn't be fast enough to make it over
that bridge you can see do do do but so
when he switches to the 16-bit world you
can see that he can run right across
there he's get to the other side and we
have other obstacles of the game you can
see the corruption on there it's kind of
hinting that if something is wrong so
when he switches to eat bit you can see
the pathway is revealed so it's kind of
like a light and dark world type of
existence so we're planning on releasing
the game later this year for pc mac and
linux we've been greenlit on steam so so
we're going to be on steam and consoles
and we're going to announce the
platform's later
you